[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on le boxeur poids welters français
hippolyte annexe le chemin de l'amérique
passe par le palais des sports cette
escale parisienne n'est pas de tout
repos de noir cubain isaac l'ogaf son
adversaire n'est pas le premier venu
malgré les encouragements le boxeur
français a beaucoup de mal à déborder
logar
fort bon styliste et boxeur puissant par
surcroît annexes s'en est rendu compte
sur un crochet au foie
il est allé au tapis pour 8 secondes et
admiratrices du français en ont encore
des inquiétudes
[Applaudissements]
inquiétude bien vaine cependant annexes
refait le terrain perdu grâce à une boxe
plus claires et des coûts plus précis un
connaisseur dans les fauteuils de ring
jean paul belmondo match nul pas
d'accord dit lois françaises juliette
gréco ne sait trop quoi en penser
de toute façon un excellent hogarth
auront sans doute une nouvelle fois
l'occasion de se départager
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après 12 jours d'une aventure étrange
l'odyssée de la santa maria est terminée
à la suite de l'entretien qu'ont dit
avoir été mouvementée avec l'amiral
américain smith le capitaine galvin a
finalement cédé il a donc débarqué à
recife les 586 passagers la santa maria
confisqué par le brésil sera rendu au
portugal
quant à henrik également il a trouvé
asile au pays du président quadros
[Musique]
le décor futuriste de la toute neuve
capitale du brésil
brasilia créé de toutes pièces dans un
désert se sont déroulées les cérémonies
d'investiture du nouveau président de la
république bien au poids de ross élu au
mois d'octobre dernier le nouveau
président âgé de 44 ans arrive au
pouvoir au moment où le brésil selon le
no2 kubitschek accompli en cinq ans un
bond de 50 ans au balcon du palais de la
présidence
le président sortant jocelyne au curry
tchèque assure les acclamations de la
foule remis son écharpe à son successeur
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue et bonne chance donc au
président pedros
double valeur sûre la belgique déjà
depuis ces derniers jours des
inondations provoquées par la montée de
la cendre jeter la désolation et la
ruine dans le borinage plus d'un mètre
d'eau dans les rues et les tristes
spectacles de cette invasion liquide
contre laquelle l'homme est impuissant
mais l'action des pluies devaient
déclencher un sinistre plus tragique un
crassier s'est répandu sur un hameau
près de liège à moulins sur fleuron un
énorme fleuves de boue noirâtre fait de
cendres et de poussières large de 30
mètres héros xii s'est rué sur une
distance d'un kilomètre ensevelissant
tout sur son passage
le roi baudouin et la reine fabiola sont
venus apporter aux populations éprouvées
le réconfort de leur présence et de leur
compassion
plusieurs centaines de sauveteurs
fouillent sans arrêt cet amas de boue et
de sangles une dizaine de maisons
écrasées 11 victimes et plus l'horreur
et la peur dans toute cette région où
les crassiers sont innombrables
tel est le nouveau malheur qui frappe le
peuple belge le voyage de la reine
elizabeth en 1/2 se poursuit avec le
cérémonial habituel
la reine et le prince philip sont
naturellement à les visiter à agra le
célèbre taj mahal véritable poème de
marbre élevé voici trois ans un parent
radja à la plus chère de ses épouses à
karachi capitale du pakistan
la souveraine a trouvé pour l'accueillir
une aide aux jeunes filles chargées de
ces étranges bijoux d'or on n'a pas
coutume sous nos ciel d'occident de voir
ailleurs que dans les vitrines des
musées l'un d'eux derajah est morte mais
elle fait encore rêver
[Musique]
le bond de l'homme dans le cosmos est
pour demain dans le berceau exactement
moulé sur son corps munis de
l'équipement complet avec lequel il a dû
se familiariser pendant des semaines le
chimpanzé nommé a choisi entre huit de
ses semblables soumises aux mêmes
entraînements a sans le moindre complexe
dans son espèce de sarcophages lexsi
glace pris l'ascenseur pour la capsule
mercury
[Musique]
celle-ci à la pointe d'une fusée
redstone devait l'emporter à la vitesse
de 8000 kilomètres à l'heure jusqu'à 250
km dans l'espace
[Musique]
c'est exactement le futur voyage du
passage et humain que le chimpanzé anne
va nous faire connaître
ares contre prévu à 60 kilomètres
d'altitude la pointe de sa fusée se
détache
puis c'est au tour de la capsule qui
contient le passager la capsule grâce à
l'énergie acquise continue sa montée
jusqu'à 250 km en a près de cinq minutes
la capsule poursuit sa course dans les
terres al'allure fall de 8000 à leurs
toits rétrofusées coupe son élan et
réduit sa vitesse
elle amorce sa dessins ses fusées leur
tâche accomplie se sépare de l'habitacle
pour réduire son poids et les parachutes
entre temps je tour à tour jusqu'à
l'océan où la capsule est attendue
disons que les pronostics ont menti et
que la capsule est tombée à 200 km plus
loin que prévu
elle se signalera aux patrouilleurs
lancés à sa recherche c'est ainsi que
deux navires la repère et que nous la
retrouvons sur le pont du donneur ou le
berceau de heim était retiré de son
habitacle and bien vivant paraissait
satisfait de cette aventure vertigineuse
qui avait duré trois heures 46 l'homme
dans l'espace est maintenant pour
bientôt
pour demain
[Musique]
au laboratoire d'optique électroniques
de toulouse l'un des principaux centres
de la recherche scientifique le
professeur dupuis vient avec ses
collaborateurs de donner à la science
une arme remarquable au regard de
laquelle le premier microscope
électronique de grandes puissances
construit par lui en 1940 fait désormais
figure de pièce de musée
[Musique]
le nouveau microscope né à toulouse
s'inscrit dans une sphère d'acier de 24
mètres de diamètre
tout le premier étage est occupé par
cette construction sur réaliste un
générateur capable de produire des
tensions de l'ordre de 1 million 500
mille volts
[Musique]
s'y ajoute un canot à électrons colonnes
dans laquelle les électrons sont
accélérées jusqu'à atteindre la vitesse
de la lumière 300 mille kilomètres à la
seconde
[Musique]
enfin lui faisant suite à l'étagé
inférieur surmontée par son coffrage de
protection contre les rayonnements
voici le microscope proprement dit trois
mètres de haut
quatre lentilles 4 tonnes toute cette
masse pour en arriver au petit espace
ménages est au centre de cet élément
une petite surface de quelques 3 mm de
diamètre sur laquelle sera concentrée le
faisceau des électrons
à l'extrémité de cette pointe le monde a
observé dont les éléments sont de
l'ordre du millionième de millimètre
avec ce microscope le plus puissant à ce
jour on aura une vision parfaite de ce
qu'on avait pu jusqu'ici qu'entrevoir et
voici la technique de l'observation deux
caméras de télévision serviront au
centrage du faisceau d'électrons
[Musique]
la mise en place de l'objet à observer
sera naturellement extrêmement
rigoureuse la traduction de dangereux
rayons x enfin ne permet pas à
l'opérateur de rester sur place
une fois le générateur mise en marche
tout sera dirigée de la salle des
commandes ou les deux récepteurs de
télévision permettront de régler
l'ultime mise au point c'est grâce à cet
instrument qu un énorme pas en avant
vient d'être fait dans la proche de
l'infiniment petit puisqu'on peut on
atteindre des grossissements de l'ordre
de 50 mille fois mais c'est peu de chose
par rapport à la possibilité d'isoler du
vide mortelle dans cette cellule les
bactéries à observer
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que l'équipe du professeur
dupuis a pu pour la première fois au
monde obtenir des photographies d'une
bactérie vivant tu grossis ici dix sept
mille fois
ici 22 mille fois et ici 24 mille fois
l'instantané définitivement visible de
la vie
[Musique]